I started hearing whispers
of Thrawn’s return as heir to the Empire.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
This will be my full Star Wars
Ahsoka Episode 1 video and Easter Eggs.
There's a whole bunch of stuff.
A whole bunch of references
to classic Star Wars, Star Wars
Rebels, the Clone Wars, even the stuff
during Knights of the Old Republic
confirming a lot of our theories.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
I'm doing videos for all the episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything
I've also got some extra Star Wars
echo dots to give away too.
To all you have to do to enter that
giveaway is just be a subscriber
and post your favorite Easter egg
from the episode on the video.
Careful for spoilers.
If you haven't seen the episode yet,
this will just be for episode one.
I'll do a separate video for episode two
that'll post tomorrow
just starting at the beginning
of the episode,
working our way through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs,
WTF moments and all the cool lure
that Dave Filoni included, Generally
the series is meant to feel a little bit
like Star Wars Rebels Season five.
Now you don't need to watch
every single episode of Rebels.
If you didn't watch those animated series.
like there is a speed run version
of a circus storyline
through Clone Wars, Star Wars
Rebels, and Tales of the Jedi.
So there are like some essential episodes
that I would recommend watching.
really good examples.
There's some deep lore here for the mortis
gods.
You only get that during the Clone Wars
episodes in a little bit.
During Star Wars, rebels like you wouldn't
get that if you only watched the movies
or like the Mandalorian episodes
also all the Knights Sisters stuff.
Probably one of the coolest Easter eggs
they bring back from the Lord.
I was waiting for them to do Night Sisters
in Live Action at some point
did not expect them to do it during Ahsoka.
a lot of people
wondering if we'll ever see Cal cast
as Show up on The Mandalorian
or the Ahsoka episodes or some point
or maybe The Mandalorian movie.
It's always possible
he is alive during this.
Part of the timeline in Merrin is also
a Knight sister, just like Morgan Elsbeth.
Dave Filoni said he made
a couple of changes for this live action
series from Star Wars rebels.
There's some overlapping timeline,
like some of the scenes during episode one
are just like live action versions
of scenes that we saw during Rebels.
But he made a couple minor changes
to the lore and practically like the way
they do the special effects
and the makeup for instance, ahsoka's Lego
like her head tails are way longer
and more accurate to what
they were like during rebels and Clone
Wars than they were on The Mandalorian.
another big reminder to that
Sabine Wren is also a mandalorian,
just like Bo-Katan, just like Mando.
She even has Mandalorian armor
from Star Wars
rebels that we see during the episode.
I'll explain that in a second too,
because there is some overlap here
with what happened
at the end of Mandalorian.
Season three.
actual episode
opens with the sound of drums
like a classic samurai film,
because Classic Samurai that was classic
Kurosawa Samurai films
inspired the original Star Wars trilogy.
So George Lucas was always a huge fan
of Samurai films, when Dave Filoni and Jon
Favreau started doing The Mandalorian,
they said that they wanted it
to feel kind of like a space Western,
like the classic star Wars movies.
But when Dave Filoni started
doing the Ahsoka series,
he said he wanted it to feel kind of
like a classic samurai feel, kind of like
a circus episode of The Mandalorian Season
two, same basic vibe.
So let's lay this whole opening
crawl here.
Also very classic Star Wars.
To have an opening crawl
feels like it came
right out of a Star Wars Samurai film.
the other important detail a lot of you
might have recognized here, too,
is that the Star Wars logo in the opening
crawl are in red lettering.
That's a reference to the end of Star
Wars, the Clone Wars.
When the letters were in red,
The reason why it changed to Red
is because it was mostly a reference
to an Afghan Skywalker
falling to the dark side
and turning to Darth Vader.
They were a couple of Big
Anakin Skywalker references in Darth
Vader references during the episode
two Wisdom Classic trilogy
music used throughout the entire episode.
You probably noticed
there were music cues for Star Wars
rebels, music
cues from things
from the original trilogy,
all kind of mixed together
into brand new music
there were a lot of visual references
and verbal references to original trilogy
and classic stuff too, like clone
Wars, Star Wars Rebels,
basically a mishmash of Easter eggs
from all over the Canon.
the sinister agents that it refers to
are Morgan Elsbeth, the Shadow
Council, Thrawn himself back in school
and Shin Hati his apprentice.
it explains the basic
premise of the series
that Ahsoka is trying to learn
where Thrawn is and keep him
from galvanizing the Remnant Empire
so that they won't
try to overthrow the New Republic,
which obviously they eventually do
wind up doing.
they also quickly recap her backstory
from The Mandalorian in the book of Boba
Fett with the way that she captured Morgan
Elsbeth and learned of Thrawn existence.
Like, Wait a minute, he's still alive.
Oh, crap, Then we pick up with the brand
new New Republic prison ship.
When they reference home.
One ship that's meant to be the flagship
of the New Republic fleet
that Ahsoka goes to later.
Not this particular ship.
this is just meant to be a brand new
new Republic design that serves as Morgan
El's best temporary prison.
They made a reference
to this whole phenomenon
during the Mandalorian season three.
the whole idea is that
they were in the process
of decommissioning
all the old imperial ships
and the old rebellion ships like this.
What you see all these bones
of star destroyers all over the place.
so later, when Herod talks
about their quote unquote, brand new ship,
that's what she's referencing,
like they're brand new designs, Basically,
this whole opening scene is just ballin
Skull, Ensign, Haiti breaking Morgan
Elsbeth out of that New Republic prison
ship in a lot of these references,
go back to the original trilogy
to like all of their verbal references.
the older clearance code
is Return of the Jedi Easter Egg,
the older Jedi code leftover
from the days of the New Republic
before Revenge of the Sith
that's meant to be a reference
to Balyan Skoll origin,
which they kind of tell you
throughout the episode.
Basically,
he is a Jedi who survived Order 66
in the Clone Wars and just went to ground
and became a mercenary in the outer rim.
That's how he hooked up with Morgan
Elsbeth, who has been quote unquote,
paying him very, very well
while he continues to train his apprentice
in his own pursuit of the force,
when they exit the ship,
that's also a reference
to both Darth Vader Emperor Palpatine
exiting their transport
during Return of the Jedi.
Like very mysterious, very sinister
sounding exit of a ship.
Captain Hale and his subordinate here,
Jack Ross, are both brand new characters.
They don't exist in the Lord.
Before this,
they just created them for the show.
He calls them on their bluff.
They're definitely no Jedi
in the whole scene.
Show me your ID.
You don't need to see my ID. Obviously.
A reference to Obi-Wan Kenobi
during a new hope.
only their response
is to basically slice them all in half.
Now, when he says they're no Jedi,
they're also not meant to be Sith
like they're not for Seth.
That's why they're lightsabers
are meant to be orange, not for red.
The orange color, also an Easter egg
for a classic original trilogy stuff.
some of you might remember this,
I believe it was the older posters.
Some of the posters would show
Darth Vader's light saber
as orange
just because of a coloring imperfection.
But the whole idea is that they're light
sabers.
Being orange
just means that Bill in school
is pursuing his own path through the force
the same way the soldier is like
they don't
follow the traditional Jedi teachings,
but they also don't lean completely.
Sith kind of the same thing that's
going on with the Grogu's character.
On The Mandalorian
pursuing his own path through the force.
That's not traditional Jedi,
right now in the timeline, Luke Skywalker
is technically the only person
who is pursuing a traditional Jedi path
because he's trying to create
that traditional Jedi Academy
or recreate an academy.
during his epic hallway run here,
you could just feel Dave Filoni
behind the scenes going,
you know what, Darth Vader
had a really awesome hallway fight.
Luke Skywalker got an awesome hallway
fight in The Mandalorian that I did.
I'm going to do that on my Ahsoka series.
Now to only I'm going to make it
for another dark side character.
Notice when he rescues Morgan.
LS Beth also meant to be a bit of a twist?
Easter egg for Luke Skywalker
rescuing Princess Leia on the death Star.
And you notice
when she tells Balyan Skoll about Ahsoka,
he isn't surprised by the knowledge
because he knows who Ahsoka is
and a Skywalker who he knew at the Academy
before Order 66, before the events
of Revenge of the Sith used to talk about
Ahsoka with him all the time.
So the whole idea is
that when Morgan Elsbeth is like,
you need to watch out for Ahsoka,
he's like, Oh, her.
I remember her wall this is going down
on the other side of the galaxy, Ahsoka
is searching the ruins of the Knight's
sister temple on the planet Arcana
for the special star map,
which is from Knights of the Old Republic.
But I kind of think that Dave Filoni
is saying here that the Knight Sisters
themselves created the map
because of the temple here in the way
that it exists when Ahsoka is saying
that the planet used to be a knight's
sister stronghold thousands of years ago,
she's talking around the same time
as the Jedi Mandalorian Wars.
So this is like the tail
end of the Old Republic era.
within the canon, it was the ancient
ricotta empire that created
the original star maps,
and they far, far predate the Jedi in
everything that happened
during the Old Republic.
They're ancient beyond measure.
so the idea is that the nice sisters
might have just been taking advantage
of ricotta and technology
that they found when they came along.
but the cool thing
here, though, is the confirming.
Morgan Elsbeth is a nice sister.
I don't remember that
they did that on The Mandalorian.
Maybe some people talked about
at the Mandalorian episodes came out,
but this is huge.
It explains so many things about her
character, mostly how she's able to go toe
to toe with the soldier.
Like she'd be just as powerful
as Ahsoka is, is the whole idea.
Is it Caesar?
Just practice the force
in a very different way.
They connect with the force
in a different way,
which is why
all their powers are so different.
anyone who played the Jedi Survivor
or Jedi Fallen order games
knows all about Mirren's powers.
Basically, that's like the host of Night
Sister Abilities.
They have all kinds of crazy powers.
most of this scene with Ahsoka,
though, is her going for Indiana Jones
in the Star Wars universe,
because Indiana Jones is George
Lucas's other big franchise.
but the idea is that
the star map is going to help him locate
where Thrawn and Ezra Bridger went,
where the space wheels took them.
The Pergolas.
that's why we saw the Pergolas at the
beginning of the Mandalorian Season three.
Like Rogue, who sees them in hyperspace,
had a big story
arc during Star Wars rebels.
But the idea is that
their race just lives in hyperspace.
They can navigate hyperspace
naturally Notice
when she's looking at all
the carvings in the room, too,
she starts to hear
whispers of four spears.
Thus the whispers of the night sisters
calling to her through the force.
Because this area is strong in the force.
zoom in, in hands on the floor there.
The patterns on the floor,
like the carvings, are also
the same designs of the mortis gods.
During those episodes, the Clone Wars.
When a soldier and a King and Obi-Wan
meet them, they're couple reference
to the mortis gods later to they did
mortis gods also during Star Wars rebels.
So like they're really really big
in the Dave Filoni canon.
She calls Hu Yang for help.
He's played by David Tennant years
voiced a little bit at the beginning here.
He's the same Jedi scholar droid that
we saw during the Clone Wars who has plans
for every single lightsaber ever created.
he's meant to be.
About a thousand years
old, older than Master Yoda,
but not quite as old
as some people think that he is.
Like he's not an old Republic era droid.
she gets attacked by throngs. H.K.
droids.
Technically,
they serve Morgan Elsbeth right now,
but they have a cool lightsaber battle
just to start things off,
show you some of her skills
and how quick she is
and how good their special effects
have gotten.
trick that Trixie uses cutting holes
in the floor with her two lightsaber
she use all the time on Clone Wars
and during Star Wars Rebels or IP.
This ancient night Sister Temple.
You can see Morgan Elsbeth later in
the episode when she comes back like me.
And this sucks.
They had to blow it up, shed a little tear
for the destruction of her culture here.
she uses the force jump
to make it back to her ship and she and Hu
Yang just have some witty banter together
to give you an idea
for their relationship.
very sassy the way that he was during
the Clone Wars episodes.
Like his personality is the exact same
He references
standard Jedi Mission protocol
and how he's still subject
to his programing
given to him by the ancient Jedi Order
a thousand years ago.
Despite the fall of the order in
present day, his programing still remains.
So he keeps going back to that
He also references the roles of Jedi
Paragons because he spent most of his time
helping Jedi younglings
construct their lightsabers.
He's also typically accustomed
to dealing with paragons and younglings to
And he knew Ahsoka
when she was a Jedi Padawan.
lot of people.
Also sensing, too, that this whole map
MacGuffin is similar to the MacGuffin
during Force awakens
like they needed to find the star map
to get to Luke Skywalker.
They're couple familiar things,
but most of the references during
this are to the classic stuff
like Star Wars Rebels, the Clone
Wars, the prequels
in the original trilogy,
and stuff that happened
during the Mandalorian episodes.
the other joke here
too, is about Asuka breaking Jedi protocol
when she used her powers
to get Morgan Elsbeth to tell her
where the star map was like, Oh,
I convinced her using my Jedi mind trick.
Both aniket and Ahsoka were famous
for never following Jedi protocol.
It was one of the big memes of the Clone
Wars like Obi-Wan Kenobi,
kind of shepherding
two little chickens who would never listen
to what they were told to do.
Notice when the New Republic flagship,
whom one calls her,
they reference her as Fulcrum.
That's her role during Star Wars
rebels during the rebellion.
the whole idea that during the rebellion
she served
is sort of the point of communication
between the disparate rebel cells.
So like during the events of Star Wars
and or before the original trilogy,
she was still serving as Fulcrum.
But mostly we saw that during Star Wars
Rebels, notice.
When they come back
to the New Republic fleet,
she clocks the iron cannon battle damage
on the New Republic ships.
That's meant to be from skirmishes
that they've had with the Remnant
Empire's forces, like the Shadow Council
and all their different factions.
we get a reunion with Hera,
who's played by Mary Elizabeth Winstead.
General Sin
Dula is a reference to the rebellion.
She was a general.
She even gets reference
during the events of Rogue One to Notice
when she gets off her ship too.
There's a guard droid walking behind her.
There's always a gantlet
like somehow there's always a guard droid
walking around in the background
randomly in all these different Star Wars
series and movies can have a new episode
without a gag droid somewhere.
The briefing room is meant to be
the exact same kind
that they used during Return of the Jedi.
There's also a bunch of music cues
from the original trilogy
that John Williams classic music.
the reason why Ahsoka doesn't remember
Balyan Skoll is because she left
the Jedi Order.
Balyan Skoll knows exactly who she is.
He remembers all the talks
that he had with Aniket about her.
she says these days
there are few who can wield the force.
That's a reference to pretty much
all the different force users
that we've seen on the show,
like the brand new Dark Jedi.
Morgan Elsbeth,
who is now confirmed nice sister, meaning
that she's also a force sensitive, too.
but also to characters like Grogu, who
we haven't seen come on the series yet,
will probably cross over at some point.
You also have Luke Skywalker in Leia.
We'll see
if they cross over to the series two.
Probably not Leia, maybe a Luke Skywalker
crossover, at least by the Thrawn movie.
can't have a giant Thrawn Star Wars movie
without a Luke Skywalker cameo.
They referenced the star maps literally
from Knights of the Old Republic,
confirming all of our theories.
she also references
the last remaining grand admiral.
Now, notice in the canon there were
only 12 grand admirals, but the Emperor
secretly named Thrawn, his 13th
grand admiral, I believe it was number 13.
Like Thrawn was like an extra secret
grand Admiral.
Normally grand admirals
would be about the rank of Grand Moff,
but technically, Grand Moff
Tarkin was the most powerful person next
to someone like Darth Vader who held kind
of a special position inside the Empire.
He wasn't traditional military
like Grand Moff Tarkin was,
but he was just as powerful,
So if he had a giant meeting
and they were all standing together,
technically grand Moff Tarkin would lead
the meeting and Grand Admiral
Thrawn would be, like, just under him
one of the reasons
why Thrawn wasn't around
during the original trilogy, though, is
because during the events of Star Wars
rebels during the ending,
he basically got jumped to the outer
rim by the space rebels.
So he was gone
for the entire original trilogy.
just a speed run throngs back story
the canon version of his backstory.
So during the Clone Wars and again
Skywalker who's still on the lights
like he's in turn to Darth Vader yet
accidentally bumps up against space
and finds the chests and learns of grand
Admiral Thrawn existence.
Thrawn very shrewdly senses
that if the Emperor learned
where the chests were
and learned in the unknown regions,
The Empire was subjugate
his people just like they did
for everyone else in the galaxy.
So in order to try and save his people,
Thrawn basically
threw himself on the street
like sacrificed himself
by turning himself in to the Emperor
and promising to serve him
with his superior mind in exchange
for leaving the choice alone.
now Thrawn
still tried to be a good grand admiral,
like he still served the Emperor well.
But it was basically a long con,
like he wanted to do everything he could
to just save his people.
Now the idea is in present day.
Thrawn believes that he can do
a better job of managing the Galaxy
than the New Republic is doing
because they were shown
to be pretty ineffectual
during the events of The Mandalorian.
that's why Thrawn doesn't
want the Emperor to come back like
he doesn't like the Emperor.
Pretty much nobody, with a few exceptions,
don't want the emperor
to come back like Moff.
Gideon definitely didn't want the Emperor
to come back In the other thing
that's during the Mandalorian Season three
is that most everyone, like the Shadow
Council,
don't like Thrawn either that much, mostly
because he outshines and he's
so much better than the rest of them.
most of the Thrawn Easter
eggs in the episode are from Star Wars
rebels though, and what he did
during the events of rebels.
A lot of the series in the Thrawn movie
are borrowing from the original Thrawn
trilogy of books heir to the Empire
Dark Force Rising in Last command.
if you really want to go on the deep dive,
I would definitely recommend
checking out the original Thrawn trilogy
because it is an amazing trilogy of books,
even if not all of it
is going to still be canon.
Not everything.
Some of it though
the Heidi and present day though
is that Hera
apparently thought that he died
at the Battle of Luthor,
which is basically the ending of Star Wars
rebels.
So when the space rebels
jumped the Seventh Fleet, his fleet away,
they assumed that he died.
But they also think that this might mean
that Ezra is still alive
to The mon calamari that yells at them
to might actually be Admiral Ackbar
because he was still very much alive
during these events up to the events
of Force Awakens,
he got killed by the Starkiller base.
then they go back to Luthor.
They're celebrating the anniversary
of the Battle of Luthor,
unveiling the mural from Star Wars.
Rebels like this is right
out of the end of rebels
with the crew, the ghost,
the lone wolves drawn in the same style
of the animated series characters.
But in the context of the series, it's
meant to be Sabine and as art.
Like she painted the mural.
Governor Izadi here is played by
Clancy Brown, which is a big Easter paper,
Star Wars Rebels, because he also played
that character during Star Wars rebels.
It's like another person
who just came back as the live action
version of their character,
just like grand Admiral Thrawn,
who's being played by Lawrence MIKKELSON
as he did during Star Wars Rebels
Governor Azari used to be an imperial moff
during rebels like Moff Gideon,
but he eventually started
helping the rebels.
He was basically in charge of all this
area during the days of the Empire,
which is how he connected
with all the rebels characters.
the whole thing.
With Sabine
Red ducking out on the dedication
speech, acting very rebellious
is meant to be the way that Ezra Bridger
used to act when they first met.
The whole idea is that
she was more classical mandalorian
when they first met more about order,
about duty.
But over time they grew so close that
her personality started to be more like
his Senator GI Cal was also a character
from Star Wars Rebels.
He worked with the crew of the Ghost
and Eventually he became the Senator
for Luthor in the New Republic.
the first shot of Sabine riding on her
bike really fast away from
the city, is also meant to be a reference
to Ahsoka
returning during the final Clone Wars
episodes, kind of doing the same thing
Dave Filoni now canonizing the E wing
classic deep cut from the Dark
Empire series and this R2 unit is actually
based on the prototype
for the original R2-D2 toy.
back at her apartment,
you know, she a pet loft cat,
which is basically like the low
thorn version of a cat.
It even purrs.
It acts kind of like a cat
all of her graffiti artwork from Star Wars
rebels is all over the place.
Like this is her graffiti,
pretty much all the items
lying around are from Star Wars.
Rebels like this pile of stormtrooper
helmets.
this is Ezra Bridger,
Stormtrooper helmet from rebels.
her Mandalorian armor is underneath here
obviously she puts it
back on in episode two.
But this is right out of Star Wars rebels.
Remember,
she is a mandalorian, just like Bo-Katan.
She's from House Ren
there were reports that she was supposed
to have a cameo scene
at the end of Mandalorian season three,
when they retook the planet Mandalore
because why wouldn't clan Ren
also be there?
I think it was more of a budget thing
because Temuera Morrison said
that he, as Boba Fett,
was supposed to have a cameo scene
in The Mandalorian Season three finale,
but they didn't actually wind up doing it,
probably because of budget.
She listens to Ezra Bridgers
message to her again
that he recorded before he disappeared
with the space whales at the Pergolas.
all the other stuff in the container.
Here were his belongings
or his belongings.
Notice
Ezra is wearing his suit from rebels.
He's played by Amon as Bondy.
I don't know
which episode will actually see him in,
like when they actually do
wind up finding him.
It might not be till later in the series.
notice in the wall behind her, too.
We see some lost cats in lone wolves.
I wonder if we'll see
some of the lost wolves
because they're actually pretty powerful.
based on his message,
talking about making this sacrifice,
doing the Jedi thing, making the hard
choice to get rid of Thrawn.
It sounds like he recorded it
before he left to take down Thrawn
at the end of Rebels.
hear the references about becoming a Jedi
are also meant to foreshadow Sabine Wren,
resuming her Jedi training
with the Ahsoka separately, Baylan Shin Hati,
the former inquisitor Marrok here,
who we haven't really seen do
much yet in Morgan Elsbeth
track Ahsoka back to Lowe though.
when she says she's the nicest survivor,
like I'm a survivor, that's also meant
to be a reference to Balyan Skoll
because he's survived order 66.
The reason why Morgan Elsbeth is
still a nice sister in surviving order 66.
Because the Empire tried to kill
all the Knights
sisters
is because she started serving grand.
Admiral Thrawn, So essentially
Thrawn saved Morgan Elsbeth,
which is why she's loyal to him.
Sabine starts getting some force
visions of Ezra in her sleep,
mostly dialog from his message, replaying
that wakes up as Ahsoka passes by.
And this is meant to be the exact same
scene from the end of Star Wars Rebels.
But in live action,
this is a bit of the overlap with that
very end scene from Star Wars Rebels.
whole idea is there's beef between her
and Ahsoka because at some point
during their training,
after the events of rebels,
but before the events
of the original trilogy,
a soldier just took off into the outer rim
to just meditate and stew by herself
because she is such a loner.
notice.
She winds her back
with the mention of Ezra's name
that they go back to is Ahsoka ship.
She sees her graffiti from her old bunk
after the events of Star Wars rebels
when she was serving as her Padawan.
their couple music cues from Star Wars
rebels do end, even though Chopper doesn't
come back till episode two.
These are some scribbles of Chopper.
when Sabine is wondering if Ahsoka gets
tired of never having a permanent home.
The whole idea is that Sabine
stayed on Luthor because she promised
Ezra that she would take care of Lothar
in his absence.
They referenced more their history as Jedi
master and apprentice
relationship and confirmed
that Sabine was a Jedi Padawan
and is also for sensitive
answering the question once and for all.
A lot of people wondering
how they were going to play this.
No, they're just saying
that Sabine always was for sensitive.
they hinted at it during Star Wars rebels,
but they never fully explored it,
like they were just kind of ambiguous
about it, I think, because Dave
Filoni wanted to save it for something
later are a couple more Clone
Wars Easter eggs
here, too. For who? Yang's character.
He's able to analyze Baylan and Shin Hati
lightsabers because he has a database
of every single lightsaber
ever constructed by the Jedi Order
so he can figure out who they are
just by looking at the lightsaber. Hilts
But the thing here is that
he can't identify she hates lightsaber
is because it was brand new was created
after the fall of the Jedi Order.
That's how they deduced that she is
Balyan Skoll's apprentice.
Oh, he's
teaching her in the ways of the Jedi,
even though they are not Jedi themselves.
the scene of her
clocking Sabine with the probe
droid, also very similar to Darth
Maul, tracking quite gone
Jyn Obi-Wan Kenobi and again,
enduring Phantom Menace.
Notice
when Sabine starts examining the star map.
You also started to hear more
whispers of the Nine Sisters,
whispers from four spirits around her to
Then Ahsoka starts talking about
Enoch and Skywalker with Hera.
Weren't you separate?
Didn't you have the same kind
of relationship with your master
in talking about musical cues
like musical Easter eggs
for the classic trilogy, for the prequels
for Clone Wars when they mentioned
and again Skywalker
it plays the darker Darth Vader music too
because of ahsoka's trauma like her
regrets of what happened when she says
sometimes leaving for the right reasons
have the wrong consequences.
That's actually a reference
to the way she always blamed herself.
What happened with Anna in falling to
the dark side, turning into Darth Vader?
She actually blames herself
that he did that.
she feels like
if she'd stayed with the Anakin
and had left the Jedi Order,
which we saw during the Clone Wars.
Like she makes a big reference
that I left the order
she feels like
had she been with and again,
she would have been able to help him
with his troubles,
like with his force visions
and none of the bad stuff
would have happened
during Revenge of the Sith Order.
66 wouldn't have gone down the same way,
and he wouldn't have fallen
to the dark side.
When Sabine unlocks the star map,
the location that it shows is it
for where Thrawn is?
It's where the space wells took them
at the end of Rebels, Thrawn and Ezra
just happened to be in the same place
when they were taken. There.
we get another cool lightsaber
fight between Zeenat
and Sabine,
also her fighting the K droids,
the green lightsaber that she grabs
is Ezra Bridgers original lightsaber.
He left it with Chopper
and that's where she got it from.
Here's the important thing, though.
She's clearly outmatched by Shin Hati.
Like they're both Jedi apprentices.
But Sabine hasn't trained in a long time,
so she's way outmatched at this point
in the series.
I think the idea is that by the end of
the series she'll had caught up to her.
She'll be about an even match for her.
But that's why she hates fighting style.
It seems much more traditional Jedi.
She's using traditional Jedi
fighting forms the same way that Anakin
Obi-Wan Balyan Skoll would have learned
when they were at the Jedi Academy.
Luke Skywalker's fighting style
with a lightsaber.
It's a little more raw
because he only got to train with Yoda
and Obi-Wan
for a little while before they died,
and they kind of
had to figure it out on his own
as he went along.
that's why Shin Hati's fighting style
Seems much more refined than Sabine's.
she runs her through.
Obviously, she's going to survive because
we know she's in the rest of the series.
but they end with a title card dedication
to Ray Stevenson because he passed away.
May he rest in peace.
I don't know what they're going to do
with the character in season.
Do but the actual end credits
are basically the same star
map designs that you saw
in the ancient Knight's sister temple.
But in full color
and they show you a lot of the space
most depictions of the space whales
lot wolves
a lot of designs that you saw in the world
between worlds as well to.
there were so many Easter
eggs in references during the episode,
if there were any, that you spotted that
I didn't talk about during the video,
just write them below
in the comments in my full episode
to video, we'll post Wednesday morning.
make sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Click here for that for episode two video
did the link as soon as I post that and,
click here for all my other Star Wars
Ahsoka and Mandalorian videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!